if you are a minor that's traveling  alone for the first time it's really  easy to find all of the information that  you need right on united.com so simply  go to united.com there's a dedicated  section for unaccompanied minors and it  will basically go step by step and tell  you the process to from booking to what  happens when you arrive at the airport  from what happens during the flight to  then what happens when you get on the  other side at your destination and we  ensure that we're making sure to keep  that individual safe along the entire  journey make sure that they're never by  themselves and that there's always  someone with them to make sure that  they're safe and able to get directly to  their destination